uh duh
hey there
if you do anything wrong in your life
duh and i find out about it i'm gonna
try to take everything away from you and
i don't care what i find out could be
today tomorrow 15 20 years from now if i
find out you're [ __ ] dude finished
who who's that
that's you
that's what the audience sounds like to
me
that's why i don't be coming out doing
comedy all the time cause y'all [ __ ]
is the worst [ __ ] i've ever
tried to entertain in my [ __ ] life
are you surprised though by the by the
criticism that's that's come your way no
and i don't mind that that people get
upset some of this criticism like is
helpful like i get educated by it i
don't necessarily agree with all of it
but i learned about
a lot of things
you know just from my critics i am not
saying that to say
that trans
women aren't women
i am just saying
that those [ __ ] that they got
you know what i mean
i'm not saying it's not [ __ ] but that's
like
beyond [ __ ] or impossible [ __ ]
tastes like [ __ ] that's not quite what
it is is it
it's not blood that's beet juice
[Applause]
but you guys got to remember i'm not
saying it to be mean
i'm saying it because it's funny
and everything's funny until it happens
to you
if bad things happen to someone else
that's not that's not necessarily funny
look at it this way
i grew up in the crack epidemic i tell
jokes about i grew up in the crack
epidemic
and now there is an opioid epidemic
are they treating the opioid epidemic
the way that they treated the crack
epidemic
no this is a national health emergency
when we were coming up we were policed
by the national guard addicts were
criminals
now they understand addicts are sick
people and maybe it's because the
demographic
of the opioid epidemic is not the same
demographic
of the crack epidemic racially i mean
we're talking about race right so now
that your community is getting destroyed
is a whole nother ballgame
and then you have it's a huge window of
empathy oh my god we can see each other
we both went through similar pain but
i'm just saying everything's funny is
what happens he was more about
is more about empathy that you
there but for the grace of god
[Music]
but there's a more important reason that
i would stop doing comedy right now
and this reason is the real reason
that's been percolating and it really is
the crowd not you
i'm talking about
the crowd on the big stage it's too hard
to entertain a country whose ears are so
brittle
[ __ ] are so sensitive the whole
country is turned into
bitch-ass [ __ ]
everything you say upsets somebody
you know i can remember when it all
started it was when i was doing
chappelle show when i was doing
chappelle show
i just do the show and then on the
weekends i do like concerts and [ __ ]
like that so i'm doing a concert and
there was a couple in the front row
beautiful couple the wife
wife was obviously asian
you can see it in her face
the husband
this [ __ ] was mysterious to say
the least
couldn't quite pinpoint where he was
from caramel colored fella very nice
hair but it could have been from
anywhere bangladesh mexico i can't guess
with a [ __ ] like this
all i knew for sure
about this guy
is that his wife was a [ __ ]
i could see that in her face too
no he was laughing and having a good
time and she was scowling at me at a
goddamn comedy show i couldn't figure it
out
and then i realized at some point that
she was pregnant and i was smoking on
stage i said oh my god that's probably
why she's mad so i started to put my
cigarette out but then she hit me with
one of them fake non-smoker calls
so i just kept smoking i thought to
myself [ __ ] that babe would be fine
relax
and i tried to break the tension i just
asked her it's all i said i go hey where
you guys from anyway and i could tell
that she was on to me she goes very
condescendingly she says
i'm
from
california
if you are asking my ethnicity
i am
chinese and her husband was just cool
about this [ __ ] he was like a mexican
bro
i said well i'm sorry if i offended you
by asking but you're a very beautiful
couple
and miss there's no question that you're
going to give birth to the hardest
working baby this world has ever seen
[Applause]
that's not a bad joke
she got very upset she got up to leave
immediately but she didn't just leave
she had to take one last dig at me on
the way out
i will never buy one of your [ __ ]
dvds again
dave chappelle
i said ma'am with all due respect
chinese people don't buy dvds
[Applause]
and the crowd went crazy we've all
laughing having a good time i didn't
even think anything of it and then just
three days later this lady sends a
[ __ ] letter to my promoter telling
him not to book me for shows anymore
because i was quote racist huh
and and i'm quoting her insensitive to
the nature of my interracial marriage i
was like word [ __ ] i was
and she had just done a little bit of
research
she would know that i myself am in an
interracial marriage
that's right
in fact
my wife is asian too
[ __ ] i'll see you on thanksgiving
but my wife's not chinese
she's filipino
that's right that's right and our kids
are puerto ricans somehow so there you
go
i don't give a [ __ ] about interracial in
fact you know what my mother is half
white a lot of people don't know that
right you were a little too excited but
okay
a lot of people don't believe me when i
say that but it's true you can't tell
looking at me
but if i grew my hair out
you would think he was at a [ __ ] cat
williams concert my shoes
my [ __ ] is beautiful
[Applause]
but [ __ ] are just taking it too
far i don't know why or how everybody
got this goddamn sensitive you know who
hates me the most the transgender
community